Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: Samira Kwache
Bonsoir à toutes et tous, il me revient
la responsabilité d’ouvrir le bal.
Et pour parler du futur,
donc le sujet qui nous rassemble ce soir,
je vais commencer
par vous poser une question,
à savoir est-ce que la science-fiction
ne serait qu’un divertissement ?
Pour essayer de répondre à cette question,
je vais vous inviter à vous tourner
non pas vers l’avenir, mais vers le passé,
vers les origines de la science-fiction
pour essayer de comprendre
ce qu’est cette expression
artistique particulière.
Déjà, il faut rappeler
que la science-fiction
fait partie de la grande famille
des récits imaginaires.
Les récits imaginaires sont indissociables
de la nature humaine.
Les récits imaginaires sont nés
il y a peut-être quelques centaines
de millions d’années,
voire un demi-million d’années,
peut-être plus, en fait, on n’en sait rien
puisque de cette période,
il ne reste rien.
Tout était de l’ordre
de la tradition orale.
Il va falloir attendre
l’invention de l’écriture
pour que nous parviennent
les traces de ces récits imaginaires.
Le plus vieux récit qui nous soit parvenu
aujourd'hui est vieux de 4500 ans.
Il se nomme l’épopée de Gilgamesh,
le grand homme ou le roi
qui ne voulait pas mourir.
Il ouvre le bal, lui aussi,
d’une succession de récits
qui, du fond l’antiquité,
de la préhistoire,
vont nous mener jusqu’à l’époque moderne.
Après Gilgamesh, vont s’enchaîner
les mythologies mésopotamiennes,
égyptiennes, grecques, romaines.
À la fin de l’Antiquité,
on va rentrer dans la période dite moderne
avec les épopées arthuriennes,
l'influence chrétienne des Celtes.
On pourrait aussi parler
du mythe du Golem, d’inspiration juive.
Tous ces récits mythologiques
nous racontent les relations entre
l’humain et le divin,
entre le spirituel et le matériel,
le tout mâtiné de magie.
La magie étant l'application économique
d'une économie humaine au monde spirituel.
Si je pratique tel rituel,
prononce tel mot, fait tel geste,
je suis en droit de recevoir
tel retour du monde spirituel.
Autre type de récit imaginaire
qui va nous intéresser,
pas encore de la science-fiction
et plus de la mythologie,
c’est la fable philosophique.
La plus grande,
celle que l’on connaît le mieux.
c’est Utopia de Thomas More,
publiée en 1516, qui va donner
le mot utopie que nous connaissons tous.
Après cela, les philosophes des Lumières,
vont utiliser la fable philosophique
pour diffuser leurs idées,
ils ont bien compris
la puissance d’évocation
que contenait le récit imaginaire
quand il est bien utilisé.
Baladant dans l’histoire de l’humanité,
nous arrivons en 1816 sur les rives
du lac Léman, en Suisse.
Là, une jeune femme va écrire
le premier récit de science-fiction.
Il se nomme Frankenstein
ou le Prométhée moderne.
Vous le connaissez tous, au moins de nom,
Par les films, par les bandes dessinées.
J'espère que vous l'avez lu.
Et pourquoi ?
On va voir aussi pourquoi
c’est le premier récit de science-fiction.
L’histoire raconte celle d’un docteur,
le bon docteur Frankenstein,
qui veut créer un être artificiel.
Il va dans les cimetières,
il vole des bouts de corps humains.
Ces corps humains, il les assemble
dans son laboratoire.
Et puis, son œuvre achevée,
il veut activer sa créature.
Il se sert de la source d’énergie
la plus puissante qu’il a à sa disposition
à cette époque, c’est-à-dire l’électricité
sous la forme de la foudre.
Voilà pourquoi nous sommes entrés
en science-fiction.
On a remplacé les principes magiques
par les principes scientifiques.
On parle de biologie et de médecine,
on parle de physique et d’électricité.
De plus, le coup de génie de Mary Shelley
a été d’interroger son époque.
Son époque, c’est la quête,
c’est celle de l’émergence
de la culture
de la révolution industrielle.
Cette émergence,
elle sent bien, Mary Shelley,
qu’elle va bouleverser
le quotidien des individus
et des organisations humaines.
Elle sent qu’il se passe des choses
avec les sciences, avec la physique,
avec tout ce qu’on nous annonce.
Tout au long du XIXᵉ siècle,
plein d’auteurs vont se saisir
de l’intuition de Mary Shelley.
On pourrait parler de l'enthousiaste
Jules Verne.
On va dire qu'il écrit des utopies.
Et là, je vous laisse retourner
dans vos bibliothèques
ou aller sur Internet pour voir
un peu toutes ses œuvres.
De l’autre côté de la Manche,
il faut évoquer H.G. Wells,
qui est britannique donc,
et qui est plutôt pessimiste.
On va dire qu'il écrit des dystopies.
Vous connaissez au moins
une œuvre de H.G. Wells,
C’est La Guerre des Mondes,
Adapté il y a quelques années
par Spielberg avec Tom Cruise.
Le XIXᵉ siècle en Europe
va être mis en scène
dans les expositions universelles.
Elles vont s’enchaîner,
pris dans l’enthousiasme techno centré
de la révolution industrielle.
Au début du XXᵉ siècle,
certains auteurs vont commencer
à interroger cet enthousiasme.
On pourrait parler
de Howard Phillips Lovecraft
qui va réactiver la mythologie,
qui avait été un petit peu mise de côté.
Quand il convoque ces Grands Anciens,
Cthulhu, Yog-Sothoth et les autres,
sont-ils des dieux,
sont-ils des extraterrestres ?
D’ailleurs, le narrateur
des histoires de Lovecraft
est-il vraiment témoin de ce qu’il raconte
ou est-il complètement fou ?
C'est au lecteur, quelque part,
de faire le tri.
Dans une autre veine, un autre auteur,
Jack London, que l’on connaît plutôt
pour ses œuvres d’aventures
dans le Grand Nord maritime,
lui, va nous proposer
une réflexion sociale.
Il prête ces mots,
dans un roman écrit en 1908,
à un journaliste qui enquête
sur une révolution sociale
qui aurait bouleversé
la planète entre 1914 et 1918.
Je vous laisse goûter
de la précision des dates,
ce qui permet aussi d’évoquer
cette Première Guerre mondiale
comme la fin de l’adolescence,
de la science-fiction.
Elle ne s’appelle pas encore
science-fiction,
elle est toujours un récit imaginaire.
Entre les deux guerres
vont se mettre en place des principes
qui vont servir à l’épanouissement,
à la maturité du récit de science-fiction.
Pour évoquer ces principes,
je vais vous citer quelques œuvres.
La première, en 1920,
c’est la pièce de théâtre R.U.R.
de Karel Čapek, le Tchèque.
‘Rossum’s Universal Robots’.
Cette pièce de théâtre raconte
l’émergence à la conscience
de machines anthropomorphes.
Et pour nommer ces machines,
il va créer un mot, robot,
à partir d’un vieux mot slave,
rob, qui veut dire esclave.
Aujourd'hui, robot fait partie
de notre vocabulaire.
On ne l’interroge plus,
il a été vulgarisé,
par des auteurs dont Isaac Asimov.
Mais il faut bien se remettre
dans la perspective de sa création.
Le robot a été conçu
comme un esclave de la modernité.
Autre œuvre : 1927, Métropolis.
C’est le premier blockbuster
du cinéma de science-fiction.
Dans ce film, Fritz Lang
nous propose des visions hallucinées
d’une ville tentaculaire,
met en forme une gynoïde,
un robot féminin, de manière réaliste.
Il transcende les effets spéciaux
imaginés par Georges Méliès,
quelque 20 ou 25 ans avant.
Autre œuvre, 1936,
il s’agit de l’adaptation radiophonique
de la Guerre des mondes de H.G. Wells
par le metteur en scène
Orson Welles.
La légende veut qu’à la diffusion
de cette œuvre, aux États-Unis,
les auditeurs aient été pris de panique,
croyant que, effectivement,
leur pays était envahi
par des extraterrestres.
L'histoire va plutôt nous dire que c'est
une légende urbaine, mais peu importe,
même la légende urbaine
nous dit que le récit,
quand il est bien mis en scène,
quand il est bien manipulé,
permet de libérer toute la puissance
évocatrice du récit imaginaire.
Concept, mise en forme, mise en scène.
Dernière chose pour cette période
entre les deux guerres,
c’est le mot de science-fiction.
Le mot de science-fiction a été inventé
dans les années 30 aux États-Unis,
il est indissociable
de la culture des pulp fiction.
Les pulp fiction, ce sont
des publications à très bas coût
que les gens achetaient
dans cette période de crise
et qui rassemblaient
tout un ensemble de textes
inspirés de ce que la science
pouvait nous offrir de merveilleux,
des planètes lointaines,
des extraterrestres
avec toutes les formes
possibles et imaginables.
Et quand le mot de science-fiction
est arrivé en Europe
et particulièrement en France,
bizarrement, il a été mal perçu.
Et la science-fiction a été ostracisée,
a été considérée comme une sous-culture.
Ça a duré pendant 50 ans en France.
Parce que…
Il y a plusieurs raisons,
mais la principale,
c’est que quand le mot
est arrivé en France,
on l’a compris
comme science fictionnelle,
science-fiction,
en oubliant qu’en anglais,
l’adjectif précède le déterminant.
Pour un Américain, science-fiction,
veut dire des récits ‘fiction’
de science, à base de science,
et non pas de la science fictionnelle
comme on l’a compris en France.
Cette modification a fait que,
pendant un demi-siècle, en France,
on ait déconsidéré la culture
de science-fiction.
Pourtant, durant cette période,
un nombre énorme d’œuvres
ont été produites
par des artistes tous aussi
extraordinaires les uns que les autres.
Pareil, je ne vais pas
vous faire une liste, allez sur internet
ou allez, à la pause, consulter
l’arborescence de la science-fiction.
Vous n’avez pas loin de 500 ou 600 œuvres
qui sont projetées sur cette cartographie.
J’aimerais juste vous citer deux œuvres
qui récemment m’ont frappé.
Il s’agit, d’une part, de la trilogie
“Le problème à trois corps”,
de Liu Cixin, le Chinois,
qui nous raconte l’attente de l’humanité,
qui sous deux ou trois siècles,
va être envahie par des extraterrestres.
l'Humanité le sait, elle attend.
On fait quoi ?
On se soumet, on se défend…
Il faut lire le tome 2, “La forêt sombre”,
qui contient des pages qui sont
de merveilleux essais sur l’innovation
à court, moyen et long terme.
L’autre œuvre, c’est un petit roman
de l’Américaine Becky Chambers
qui s’appelle “Apprendre si par bonheur”.
Là, elle aborde l’espace, l’exploration
spatiale sous une forme éthique,
elle interroge l’exploration spatiale
sous sa dimension éthique
Au XXIᵉ siècle,
la science-fiction fait partie
de la culture mainstream.
Elle a acquis ses lettres de noblesse,
même Arte se met à diffuser des films
que, dans ma jeunesse,
on regardait avec honte.
Mais maintenant, c'est devenu à la mode.
Soit, très bien, mais parfois,
on convoque la science-fiction
un peu à tort et à travers.
Vous vous souvenez, en 2017,
lors de l’élection à la présidence
des États-Unis de Donald Trump,
deux romans ont été exhumés des étagères
pour essayer de comprendre un peu
ce que représentait cet homme
qui bouleversait les codes de la politique
intérieure américaine ou internationale.
Ces deux œuvres étaient 1984,
de George Orwell,
et La Servante Écarlate,
de Margaret Atwood.
Dans les deux cas,
on est dans la situation
d’une société autoritaire
qui broie l’individu, qui interdit
à l’individu d’exercer son libre arbitre.
Et les femmes, dans La Servante Écarlate,
sont réduites à leur condition
de juste procréatrice.
Je ne sais pas si les lecteurs ont trouvé
des enseignements dans la lecture
de ces oeuvres,
en tout cas, cette manière
d’interroger le présent
au travers de la science-fiction
peut être une bonne manière.
Ce système va se dégager de l’analyse
ad hominem, de la personne,
une personne particulière,
pour s’attacher à des concepts.
Et par exemple, on peut s’attacher
à essayer de comprendre
ce que la science-fiction
pourrait nous dire du corps.
Le corps, dans les années qui viennent,
va être bouleversé pour maintes raisons.
Pour des raisons scientifiques, éthiques.
Prenons le cas des soins génétiques :
les soins génétiques qui promettent,
pour des personnes condamnées à mourir,
souvent dans des délais brefs ou à vivre
avec des contraintes énormes,
le soin génétique pourrait…
On pourrait imaginer qu’il se dégage
de la dimension de soins
pour aller vers une forme de dimension
par un peu plus de confort.
Imaginons un monde
dans lequel on propose aux futurs parents
le choix de la couleur des yeux,
des cheveux, la taille, la teinte
de la peau ou que sais-je encore.
Peut-être des sujets moins essentiels
ou plus subtils.
Imaginez que cela devienne une norme.
À ce moment-là, on glisse
dans une politique eugénique.
L’eugénisme étant la politique de contrôle
du patrimoine génétique d’une espèce,
de l’espèce humaine.
Eh bien prenez un film :
Bienvenue à Gattaca, d’Andrew Niccol,
qui traite exactement de cette situation,
la situation d’un individu
qui ne correspond pas
à la norme sociale eugénique.
Quelle est sa liberté ?
Où est sa liberté ?
Dans un autre domaine,
celui des prothèses biomécaniques.
Elles aussi,
ce sont des promesses extraordinaires
pour des personnes accidentées
ou qui sont victimes
de malformations congénitales.
Un très bon exemple,
c’est le cœur français Carmat,
la prothèse biomédicale,
qui va un jour battre dans des poitrines
et permettre à des gens…
De même manière,
imaginons que dans un monde,
on glisse vers des plans marketing,
vers de la publicité qui nous incite tous
ici à nous appareiller.
Que se passe-t-il si,
à un moment donné,
j’ai plus les moyens de payer
mes prothèses ?
Parce qu’il est évident,
si l’État veut bien payer un cœur
parce qu’on est dans l’ordre du soin
et qu’on va glisser dans la dimension
du confort, l’État dira niet !
Et c'est normal.
Eh bien, cette situation de conflit
entre individus et marché
est traitée dans un film comme Repo Men,
de Miguel Sapochnik.
On continue, puisqu’on est lancés,
on est dans un monde
où on peut faire plein de choses.
Imaginons un monde dans lequel la norme
soit à l’augmentation,
soit à la modification du corps.
Je peux modifier
soit mes appareils moteurs,
soit mes organes internes.
Donc je peux modifier cinq pour cent,
10, 20, 40, 80% de mon corps.
Là, on peut se poser une question :
à quel moment mon moi, mon identité,
non appareillée, change
ou n’est plus celle qui est appareillée ?
Je renverse ma question,
est-ce que je peux réduire
ma personne, ma personnalité,
au 1,4 kilo de matière grise
que j’ai dans ma boîte crânienne ?
Si c’est le cas, pas de problème,
je peux remplacer tout mon corps,
je garde que mon cerveau.
À moins que ma personnalité
soit une subtile relation
entre cette matière grise
et le reste de mon corps.
On sait maintenant qu’il y a des neurones
hors de la boîte crânienne,
hors de la colonne vertébrale.
Ces interrogations, on les retrouve
dans un film comme Ghost in the Shell,
dont la dernière adaptation date de 2017,
adaptation d’un manga qui date de 1980.
Je pourrais encore continuer à parler
des intelligences artificielles
qui un jour, pourraient s’adresser à nous.
Entre nous, on pourrait se dire
« cogito ergo sum »,
et la machine un jour nous dira
«  compute ergo sum ».
Je compute, donc je suis.
Là aussi, on pourrait évoquer un film
comme Terminator Dark Fate
qui traite de la relation entre différents
types de personnes pensantes.
Ce que je viens de faire sur le corps
à partir de quatre films
on peut le faire sur plein de domaines.
On pourrait très bien interroger
de la même manière l’écologie
en posant la question
de notre relation à la planète Terre.
On pourrait le faire par rapport au voyage
spatial et sa dimension éthique.
On pourrait le faire
par rapport à la ville.
La ville qui est un espace libre
de circulation et qui, dans l’avenir,
pourrait peut-être l’être
un petit peu moins, voire plus.
Ce que nous avons fait ici,
on l’a fait à une seule condition :
c’est en se débarrassant d’un cul-de-sac
dans lequel nous a mis
la culture de la consommation,
qui est la culture du kleenex
- vite consommé,
vite jeté et vite remplacé -
Ce qu’on va faire ensemble,
c’est simplement avoir la même attention
à la culture contemporaine,
à la culture science-fiction,
à la pop culture,
à la culture digitale, peu importe
le nom qu’on lui donne.
On va utiliser la même attention
que l’on a pour la culture dite classique.
Quand on étudie du Verlaine, du Rabelais,
du Rimbaud, que sais-je encore,
du Shakespeare ou du Victor Hugo.
Et c’est en ayant cette attention à la
culture contemporaine, à notre culture,
à votre culture, que vont émerger
tous ces gestes et tous les ferments
qui vont nous permettre d’apprendre
à comprendre les enjeux de l’avenir,
l’incertitude du futur.
Alors…
Je n’ai plus qu’une chose à vous dire
pour clore mon propos, c’est…
dans le voyage qui nous mène
vers cet avenir
qui en permanence nous percute,
eh bien, bon voyage
en terre de science-fiction.
Merci.